[Music]
good
morning gamers welcome back to another
beautiful day
in minecraft i had a live stream
yesterday and someone told me to plant
four spruce trees next to each other and
bam
whoa whoa whoa why do i feel like it's
challenging ikea tower
don't worry ikea tower you are beautiful
forever
if you didn't catch a live stream don't
worry you didn't miss much i just walked
around
and it was very peaceful and very nice
i can crit with the trident
oh my god bank can you get out of the
boat you're not supposed to
ah sorry how do i get them out
oh my god they're stuck forever lisa's
gets them out i keep forgetting
oh oh that's so cute so someone told me
they go to sleep
underneath trees that is so cute
sleep little giant sleep
oh my god i'll put a little lantern oh
okay sorry sleep sleep
just go to sleep thank you
i don't know if this is true or not but
apparently you can give them a sword as
well
because they keep stuff in their mouth
just like dark souls oh my god okay
thanks
come on you can be just like dark souls
eat it
i can give him my badass sword and it
will give him like
fire aspect and stuff this sword is very
important to me but i want you to have
it because you are important to me too
i need him to drop the leash somehow
maybe if i give him porkchop
there we go he just spits it out
oh he's eating it oh my god
yes that's so cool
so apparently he gets the enchantment we
need to try this out this is so cool
all right who wants to volunteer
all of you that's very well all right
i'm just going to leave oh look at him
look at him
look at him beg this going crazy
oh my god all right all right i'll just
leave these guys here and you can do
whatever you want them
kill them kill them now whoa the
backwards
attack look it's cooked chicken because
my
sword has sweeping edge that's so
awesome
well i guess you two are the lucky ones
oh my god he killed them as well
very very interesting technique that
bank has using is
why is the chicken just not running away
incredible technique oh they're friends
oh and now he went to sleep with little
chicken
oh my god
oh now obviously i'm still homeless
i've been trying to figure out what i
want to build and we'll probably build
something or at least start it today
i'm really excited for uh
what our new house is gonna be but this
time i wanna go big
i'm always such a swedish loser and i
was like oh i just wanna build a small
little home
for me and my pigs no not today
today we go big we go all out but first
of course
i have to terrorize my villagers yes
i have this new system set up which i
think you guys
are gonna really like sven has been
guarding them to make sure
good job sven uh so i have a
i have a very well hidden uh what is it
observer here
which if you can see there's a line of
thread here
so if anyone passes this thread observer
will notice
and the trap will activate now so far
not a single soul has managed to escape
this prison right sven
yes but just for a safety mesh no
no the boat is not for you sven you want
to be the guard boat
fine okay fine all right let's remove
this
and let's watch them walk into the trap
you're free
oh no
anyone else want to be free
why is that so funny you guys are free
you can run
look you can play both with sven
you know what to be honest i i think i
only need one right now
um let's actually feed them a bit more i
need more babies
keep eating and keep fricking oh it's
working
excellent i have to cover up the whole
thing because babies can still crawl in
through
tiny holes uh which is kind of a
nutrients and i haven't made this with
babies
oh well how do you do
okay this is perfect so this is my new
transportation system
oh yeah i showed it already well there
is a new feature to it
you see the track doesn't go up now
i put the track over here and then it
will go
up up into there was that a witch sound
oh my god where in my spawner
so i improved my spawner based on one of
you nine year olds
oh it works i'm supposed to i made it
one by one but it's better if you make
it
two by two so now you can see my
training is a little broken i get the xp
bang bang bam it's full and the loot
gets dropped in here excellent well what
you nine year olds told me or one of you
uh is that you may think this is a fun
roller coaster ride well i guess in the
way it is they get their final
final ride before the
before the eternal suffering
oh god oh they're all in here huh
so i will they will be placed here
forever and that will make more
mobs spawn if there's a villager and
they will move more towards the center
as well
i think i know one of those things is
true at least
so it's time for our annual lottery
that's right sven
one of these lucky contestants will be
randomly picked
they'll look like one giant guy hey
sorry sorry sir
one lucky contestant will get chosen as
tribute
i think this will go pretty fast but
i'll try and follow three
actually i kind of want to see them
getting picked okay sven are you ready
here we go
three two one
[Applause]
three two one here we go
and there he goes lucky winner let's
follow him sven
see i'm so nice to my villagers they get
a lucky chance to live a new life
there he is perfectly placed excellent
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm actually going to keep them in the
mine cart for now because i think i'm
supposed to get two or three of them you
know it's
it's not really fair like i haven't even
written this
i just let other people have fun it's
really not about me
all right one more lucky winner here we
go three two one
beep and we have a winner
congratulations sir
sorry i haven't really i'll get you a
job eventually
so has married lives then how how is it
i'm about to get married myself you know
cool that's good to know hey hey
get off my property oh sorry
ah it was me
damn smith's boyfriend loki savage
oh there's sven sun so cute
so you guys said that i should make
cement sun
purple because red plus blue is purple
but i wanted sven's boyfriend to be
yellow so that means green
so he's green just so we're clear
does this matter to anyone no oh right i
forgot what i was doing completely
uh i forgot about the people up here
there should be two of them up here oh
no did he push the other one down
oh no
why am i laughing
that's awful so now zombies will spawn
on these squares
they'll they'll be like oh i want him i
want his sexy body
he looks so nice oh god i'm about to
fall in the hole but i also still want
him
oh god that hole is really coming closer
but i love him
he's so sexy but oh my god i'm about to
fall into giant pit maybe there's more
of them down there
okay see you later that's how i envision
it
have fun now
cool so hopefully it works better now as
you can see i put ikea bird on my
shoulder
as honor of ikea bird thank you for your
service ikea bird
never forget it in my spaghetti man bank
looks so
cute next to dinner bones
what who left the door open
banked who left the door open
where is dinner bone oh my god
all right watch this snipe by the way
right in his face so i had this thing
for a while
in the background a lot of people seem
curious about it i literally
oh god oh no i wanted to try out because
you can make
like elevators with kelp in minecraft
i actually want to try that for a very
specific reason
okay so if i remember correctly you do
this
yeah but so we have this water flowing
in our beautiful god damn that's
annoying
but if we put one ah
no that's not what i wanted to do my
powell is too strong i mean my
shovel ah that's not what i wanted to do
either
ah okay you play soul sun here and then
you're like oh
it does oh it creates bubbles
not all the way though oh my god what is
happening
flip flip flip flip all the way up baby
winston simpson swing
then you take the soul sand did i do it
is that how you do it no
ah oh it's working i did it
i did it how do i get down from here
help do i have a bucket of water yes i
do
okay watch this gamers this is an old
veteran minecraft trick
you jump and then you drop the water
right before you fall
good thing i don't have legs because
otherwise that would have hurt let's try
that again
i never actually managed to do it here
we go
yeah you see that that's so cool oh
smooth yeah
the idea behind this is to have a sniper
tower
because oh you see that creeper over
there watch this
he despawned are you kidding me all
right watch this first try
got him moving target no problem
and another one bites the dust
man i wish sven could see me
i got him i'm looking banked
don't worry banked i got you
[Laughter]
oh i hit the pig sorry
see i swear there's a witch spawn like
oh that's far
oh my god i am the lord of triton
okay it's time gamers time to build
our new house are you
excited you should be right banked
i got a lot of spruce wood and i got a
lot of stone
and i like got a lot of patience this
time
when i build like i said
i'm gonna go bigger
[Music]
all right not a bad start right banked
oh he's sleeping
[Music]
yeah i'm building another japanese
temple whatever
they just look so awesome it's kind of
cozy underneath
as well meanwhile there's one thing i
desperately forgot
to do last time
which was building a freaking snowman
let's do it right in front of bank i
think he'll like this i don't know if
this
oh my god that's it
what why does it look like that
oh whoa that's creepy
sven is scared sven don't worry it's
safe
what are you hello
that is so creepy why does it is this a
joke like am i getting
this is the texture pack why do they
look like that
are they evil are they evil sven
oh my god they're leaving trail of snow
what he's pee pee pooping himself you
see actual pee pee poo poo
hey hey not too close so yeah my plan
with the building is obviously finishing
the temple i might have to move
i might have to move council of
watersheep which is obviously very
controversial
oh it looks like they have a watersheep
is riding the pig
it has been done my lord uh
yeah i might have to move a little bit
it's fine
oh no he's dying no
ah
damn you want their
oh my god so i don't know if this is
true or not but i heard that you can
oh my god it's thunder okay okay i'm
going back
oh bank is scared oh no
he's scared of thunder don't worry
you're safe in here
don't worry don't worry buddy you're
safe in here
so does my channeling work or does it
have to hit something to do it
oh it still works baby
oh so what happens if you do it on
different things
like a sheep they die
okay cool that's good to know
is there anything else that
i can use it on
like a spider
no zombie
it's so badass i love it so much
creeper oh man
whoa what is happening
why is he blue
what what's a blue creeper
whoa it's so cool
look at you huh oh oh
whoa
they make bigger ex whoa he dropped the
head
what wait so if a creeper blows up other
mobs
then they drop an item question mark
blow up blow up flop do it creeper oh
man
what they drop heads stop hitting me
stop i'll take their heads i think i
don't know
ah there's so many of them
back off children
i'm too strong
swedish zeus
did it drop yes
oh man oh i want an enderman head
oh let me go to sniper tower can i wear
their heads
oh my god i can't
oh my god sven is going to freak out
he's out hey sven
will
okay sniper tower let's go all right
it's sniping time
all right you see that zombie
yes yes
so this is what it's like to be a god
amongst immortals
why is this so funny it's really not
[Music]
whoa hey hey you can't do that that's
illegal
uh-oh uh why are there so many of them
here
strike them strike them all
i'm one of you guys i'm one of you guys
i swear
no head
all right that was fun though
people would be like what hey
oh my god
oh
oh i'm no i'm sorry
oh oh
oh sven i'm sorry i'm sorry it's me it's
me i promise
look look look it's me pewdiepie
[Music]
oh
oh i wanna cry
oh my god
oh god
[Music]
i was just trying to make a joke
oh my god
why am i crying
okay what happened here
i let you guys free and this is how you
repay me
i need to do fishing go in
they've turned my dock into a frick
chamber stop it
i need something to calm me down i need
something to
cool my nerves a bit i'm good old fish
and that'll always do
what there's a you can have the dragon's
head you have a human head how
sorry i'm learning about the game while
i'm playing it's really weird but you
can make
fireworks out of the heads so the creep
bread is a fire oh my god that's
so cool can you build a snowman in the
nether
no
no does it have to be snow
sorry i'm sorry
[Applause]
what if you leave a snow trail okay i
just google
you can you can make a fire assist
potion
and then they will survive in the nether
obviously i have to do that i want to
build one
that just stays here
because i like that he was just putting
snow anywhere
yeah just keep keep doing you you're
doing great buddy you're doing great
make more snow okay and then we turn it
into a splash potion
i guess we'll have to be really fast
what should i name the snowman
dumb ball
yes okay
let's see how he fares against some uh
enemies of the nether
should try and make the potion line on
me as well uh okay we're gonna have to
be really fast
first cut the pumpkin
oh god okay well will the snow just not
melt
wait how do i throw the potions again
right click
okay okay
come on come on dumbbell
okay okay i gotta make the hot keys come
on dumbbell
he got it it's working
he's throwing snowballs at them get him
dumbo
you got this man yeah
you got nothing on us
no dumbbell how are
dumbbell no he was like father to me
he was like my own oh god well
take that
the triton rules all yes
rest in peace dumbbell okay there's one
final thing i want to do
so this is a regular fireworks but then
now it becomes a creeper shape
what okay so i want one blue one
and one yellow one all right gamers
follow me
hey sven i brought all your friends
sven look they're so happy
all right guys get your seats
uh son's boyfriend there we go
oh that's so cute all right guys you
ready for this
it's a creeper face
it's so lame wow
[Music]
thought it would be a little bigger
they love it they love it
thanks for watching and out of the
episode gamers hope you enjoyed smash
like if you did
check out the merch to support the
channel sven jurgen whatever you want
we have a ton of great options and i
really appreciate it that's it for me
for now see you guys next time
bye bye